if we were able to prove that someone
has traveled from a different time it
would be very cool for science
although it might overwrite Albert
Einstein's theory of relativity
Einstein approached time as a fourth
dimension
together they form a space-time
Continuum and it can be affected by
gravity
according to Einstein's theory of
relativity gravity is a curve in
space-time
and technically because space and time
are one gravity could Bend time as well
as space
but you'd need something really really
big to notice any changes in the
movement of time
if you somehow managed to get yourself
close to a black hole like Sagittarius A
you'd be experiencing time at half speed
compared to people on earth